欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好股市又开始播放起了
大家都在等
今天的成交量又稍微萎缩了
上市量只剩下6000亿左右
在等什么呢
当然明天台指期的结算
礼拜四的联准会利率决策会议
可是大家也不明要说
这些事情不是上个礼拜就已经知道了吗
当然还加入了一个就是AI末日论
很担心AI在高速的发展下
会对人类的权益有所伤害
但真的是如此吗
昨天我们有特别独家跟大家分享
这比较像是资本市场的阴谋
不过在观望的时候
其实机会是越浮现越多
为什么大家真的要思考一下
因为现在盘面上的这些利空
不管是油价比较高啊
可能要升息啊
AI可能降规降速啊
都是已经听过的利空
所以它的杀伤力没有这么强
只是市场上变得比较闷
比较闷的话就要听听看我们来宾的想法了
因为在盘面底下暗潮汹涌
故事很多就等点那一把火
点了之后后面的利多会不断喷出哦
来欢迎他们
第一位是AI达人蔡明翰
好看到明翰哥
我们的信心就来了
他要特别提醒大家
等一下会把刚刚提到的利空
一一解读告诉大家
这些事情都不是新鲜事
尤其这几天讨论非常热烈的
AI降贵降速
在今天的盘面上
是很影响到科技股的
可是他绝对不是什么新的故事
以前就发生过了
而且大厂们的反应是什么
川普打电话给黄仁勋
在一个live的podcast
说没有AI末日
所以等一下告诉你
利空拿掉之后
营收好的股价有回档的
率先布局的第一梯次
是哪一些名和独家奖咯
第二位是古琪双分析师
继维明小明同学
今天看到建策跌停版
怎么样鬼故事又来了
之前两片变一片
现在说三片变两片
但今天的跌停版
沒有所死
所有的散熱股都有點受到影響會不會重演之前散熱股的問題呢小明同学今天也有独家的解释但看到台达电稍微翻起来咯所以契机就在这里面
另外也提到资本支出的前进脚步
丝毫没有减缓的情况下
封测股虽然今天表现也不是很理想
但快了
第四季的封测股业绩都会全面往上
现在是布局好时间
好第三位呢
是当冲破蛋双刀流高献荣
憲榮也要講現在牌面上搶的是誰呢
資安股嘛
因為黃仁軒一講到資安
Enthropic也講到資安
其實美國的資安大廠
股價都在創歷史新高哦
那我們這兩天大家會擔心
會不會是一日行情呢
因為他們以前的成交量比較冷
所以呢
憲榮說大戶已經進駐了
而且今天也幫我們檢驗
有一些最近集碟的
像所謂的金財啊
大力光啊
友達啊
大家關心的
大戶都偷偷在買哦
還有今天現榮帶來了
第三季預估會創新高的好公司
投信也在狂買
到底他們看到什麼商機
等一下告訴您
首先有請明翰
好今天非常非常需要你
因為量縮下來了
大家盤面上有很多很多的利空
擔心升息 擔心油價
擔心所謂的AI末日
我覺得最猛的是
川普居然在一個節目裡面
對不對
黃仁勳在上Podcast
他就打電話給他
那今天是明翰來上我的Podcast
看看誰會打電話給你
營收牆股價低的
你覺得就是第一T次要佈局
對 應該這樣講
現在市場確實亮說
結論就是大家有點看不懂
方向不明確
也不是說到底是多還是空
各有論點
所以導致多空都沒辦法
目前正在震盪
觀望這些到底
這些變數會長怎樣
那比較重要就是
大家現在在講AI大佬
要喊著要放慢腳步
對 但我常常講
川普聚踩煞車
我覺得這是非常非常重要的關鍵
因為畢竟決定權在他
應該說這些人他是一個賤言
他是認為應該這麼做
可是他不願意
那其中他就提到四個論點
第一個就是現在正在領先
那如果他減速等於是讓出優勢
他就在講他們對中國的關係
就是說他們現在是贏的
他不可能現在放慢腳步
第二他覺得這個末日說
有點被過度渲染了
川普真的是怕跑輸中國
所以我常常講的
它才是最重要
當然它在這個Podcast的中間這個所謂馬上call in還不開call in對 我是當然覺得也許有一點點可能本來就有這個說好的一個狀況
對有點這個概念
但是確實非常具有題材性
它會擴大大家的這個
得說大家知道這件事情的這個滲透率
其實對整個AI的部分反而是正向
其實馬斯克在2023年3月
其實就有發出一樣的警訊
當時他有發出公開信
提到要暫緩 這次是暫緩
應該說這次希望腳步慢下來
當時希望完全暫停六個月
對 當時是說希望整個AI的進展
先暫停六個月
因為當時是TradeGTV釋出來
然後他覺得當時跨越的速度太快
他說只要比這個更先進的系統
暫停訓練
他現在的說法是你訓練沒關係
但是你要上市的時候
我們先檢查一下安全性
那時候講得更誇張
是希望大家都先不要訓練
而且這個議題全球有三萬人去連署
認為他講的內容是贊成的
但是憑良心講喔
這是當時公開信說的時間點
你看我們都已經有點忘記這件事
對 大家根本就不太理他
這個股市不斷漲
當然我要先講一個重點
因為當時是在二三年
剛剛起漲AI正出來的時候
因為當時位階低
所以說完完全不理它
持續往上噴
現在位階高
稍有一點點的疑慮就會震盪
我覺得是非常合理
可是就我個人而言
我個人覺得這個真是兩天題材
就是最後抵不過那個所謂聯準會
很快大家就會忘了這件事情
當然剛剛提到油價往上
準備升息
美債殖利率最近來講也是大幅走高
看到兩年期 十年期 三十年期
尤其是十年期都已經突破5%
對 那尤其我們之前也跟大家分享
三十年期領先創高
那時候兩年期是不太動
我們那時候跟大家講短線不動
這代表著大家不認為
那麼快會做盛息的動作
只是覺得長期有壓力
結果因為最近的
剛剛提到油價上升
所以升息機率大幅走高
所以這幾天連兩年期都噴出去
所以看起來這個高殖利率
當然應該說美債殖利率大幅走高大家多少會有點擔憂可是我要講的概念真正的壓力來源一定是最後經濟出了問題股市才會大跌
而且股市大跌
你一定會看到資金賣的股
會跑到公債去
所以公債殖利率會走低
所以長期間我就講了
之前金融風暴的時間點
紅色是股市
藍色是公債殖利率
永遠都是走同向
所以我就覺得很納悶
公債殖利率往下是利空
往上也是利空
這個一聽就知道不太合理
所以其實過往經驗
你只要看到股市真的大跌
理論上公債殖利率是往下的
所以往上會導致
短時間的市場信心稍微有動搖
但絕對不會是
因為公債殖利率創高
導致股市後來呈現長期的空頭
我就要跟大家講
這概念可能要稍微去扭轉一下
好 要去釐清一下
中占持续率往下还是真正大风险
大家很害怕的时候
对 往上的话现在是反映
可能通膨要升息
是 另外就是这样升息
其实也更不用担心
有些我刚刚提到
现在九成的几率都要升息
代表这个礼拜升息就是如玉期
所以股市绝对不会
因为如玉期而崩盘
绝对不可能
那其中我永远讲
真正升息会导致股市下跌
就是2022年的时候
他一樣從0到0.25開始升息
第一次他升了1碼
第二次升2碼
第三次之後連續四次都升3碼
結論來講就是真的
最重要的是速度
並不是升息
升息其實對股市
緩步的升息
股市仍然持續往上
但是他當時的狀況是
連續四次都升息3碼
而且在這個情況下
一路從0到5.25
所以結論就是
升息其實也沒什麼好害怕的
尤其這一次幾乎都已經
市場都有所預期
最後我自己的觀點
用這個表可能會比較理解
用三種情境
對 如果這個禮拜
我們這個情境全部都是升息了
因為我個人覺得九成了
我們就以升息的交流
對 升息了
但是它的中性偏割
中性偏割應該說
要看到的是聯準會的態度
聯準會態度看兩個東西
一個是點證圖
一個是會後的主席的說法
如果中性編歌
中性編歌是什麼
就是未來的動向
他會參考經濟數據
就是他不講未來會怎樣
就是未來如果真的通膨
很嚴重我就升
如果掉下來我就不升
類似這種概念
股市來講應該就會
利空出境
可是我希望能夠利空出境
有個條件
就是這幾天股市不要反彈
就是不要漲 壓在這裡
跌不跌不重要
但不要在出來之前就反彈
我覺得對股市是比較好的
那只要
只要它偏中性
不講未來 股市就會漲
第二種情境就是偏陰了
我剛剛提到
從點證圖跟它的說法
都可以告訴你今年這一次
絕對不是只有一次升息
可能年底還有
對 年底還有
甚至有可能三次
因為它9月 10月 12月
搞不好每一次都升一嘛
所以代表著還會持續升息
那這個結論來講
就會一到兩天會有壓力
但絕對不會是長期趨勢
因為我們前段就提到
長期的這個緩步升息
對股市其實不會有明顯的壓力
但是第三種情境
就是回到2022年
好 我們再來就講
那再講到說
那奇怪就是台積電
今天雖然是撐盤要角
可是你可以看到
他趨勢一直以來
就沒有太強的一個表現
他今天不跌
中小型股好慘喔
對 他會
今天來講真的是靠他撐盤
但是我會常常講
就是現在上不去的原因
其實是因為
台股的位階真的就是比較高
因為我們對比費半
我們的位階就是高
所以我常常講費半
你不如乾脆看台積電跟ADR就知道
你可以看到高點跟對高點
後續壓回
其實台股跌勢沒有比較小
但是很快就反彈到
幾乎再回到快到起跌點
可是現在的ADR距離高點
其實還超過一成以上
所以明顯的有這個不同的差距
另外這兩張圖的位階不同
就會引發這個議價差的變化
所謂的議價差 結論而言
就是長期ADR一定比這邊貴
所以你把這個換算成
美金400多塊換算成台幣
然後再除以5回到這個價格
的這個中間的差距
只要越高
代表的就是多頭的一個趨勢
現在呢這一加差一直說減到
剩不到15%
過往經驗確實會
壓抑著這個股價表現
所以我剛剛講未來的要的是
他想辦法去突破
回到這個給突破之前的壓力區
那台股才有機會往上
記得未來一件事
如果他還在這裡震盪
但台積電想辦法去突破這千萬不要買這個簡單來講如果自己這個ADR不去突破這裡先去突破千萬不要買這一定會壓回的
我們等ADR表態
是一個很重要的事情
就是結論來講
就是要讓這個溢價差拉開了
才代表著會有多頭的一個趨勢
回到這個台積電壓抑
台積電營收創力時新高
沒辦法有效的表現
當然最近營收好的個股
其實今天來講
也都有一定的壓力
台藝店不寂寞
這邊都是營收創高
但壓力看起來現在比較大的
其實比較重要的關鍵點
應該說最近因為股市震盪
所以很多人其實也不太看
這個基本面
還會看現行
但是確實我們列出來個股
這些個股就是8月營收
創歷史新高
而且今年這個
我們看到營收年增長
還有累積的
還包含今年的獲利
其實都是
簡單來你用各樣條件塞
人家都是只有生
都是前段班
對 可是今天股價是跌的
所以我覺得記得一件事
現在震盪的時間點
反而是尋找這些
本來就是基本面好
最近拉回
反而是佈局的機會
可是這檔其實他還好
他有創歷史新高
是 我們今天來講
找到的個股
是相對比較強勁一點的個股
那當然我剛剛講的
不同的故事
這種就比較屬於
喜歡短線操作的
你可以盡量選擇比較強勢的
我們前段看這麼多個股
裡面的這個個股
反而弱的買
我覺得也沒有問題
弱的代表什麼
就是你需要一點時間
它不可能V型反彈
但是你只要時間放長
它的空間會比較大
強勢的個股代表著
你很快就有機會獲利
但是因為它位階高
所以獲利的空間
自然就會受到壓縮
沒有絕對的好與壞
那因為營收非常強勢
昨天試圖創高
今天就被壓回
所以我覺得這個短線來講
它這個趨勢來講
應該都還有機會再持續往上
那帶動不同的個股
一樣IP
我們講IP股
對 相對來講
市新就弱勢很多
怎麼了
這發生什麼事
這營收明明就好到爆啊
對 我們先講一下故事
看一下這是24年營收
這25年營收
所以前一段時間很弱是應該的
因為之前掉單
所以它的營收掉是很合理
今年上半年還在震盪
甚至比前兩年更低
那時候就在講
Amazon訂單快進來了之前那時候市場的預期都會落在三四月就會進來稍微有點延遲但還不錯 後續就噴出了可是為什麼這個月公佈之後會掉
其實很簡單
就是公司之前的法說會
很多的場合
他沒有講得很明
但是法人從他的言語之間
大家都預期
可能應該有機會突破100
結果出來的數字
有一點點不如預期
還要比這個數字更好就對了
因為你可以看到它的斜率
在這個月確實有一點點的比
等於說跟之前的斜率稍微有不同
所以可以看得出來
結果是有點不如預期
大家都原本預期會過100這條軸線
但是憑良心講
因為它的
它接到了Amazon的這個單
是一個套餐
所以代表著
它不會到這裡就是頂一點
所以我個人覺得在這裡壓回
倒不用過度緊張
不要 一樣問題
我常常講多看數字
不要永遠都看線型
人家的營收其實長這樣
只是這個月
大家有點點得過度樂觀
出來沒有到達那麼樂觀的情況下
反而壓回
但我覺得未來它不會到
簡單來講這個營收不會是高點
未來還有機會再往上
所以我覺得也不用緊張
因為今天ASIC相關的IP股
都是比較壓抑的
就是被那個降規降速
可能有點影響到了
應該說今天IP都弱
但是剛好市新是在
公布營收就已經轉弱
會導致他今天看起來又特別弱勢
會有這個雙重的壓抑的效果
那我們講到金居
他就算是相對比較穩健
所以我們今天來講也算是
他也算是盡量看能不能短線
就盡快轉強
因為他的走勢
之前相對樣弱勢的時間很長
他等於說比市場
比較容易發現打底之後
開始轉強
所以我覺得短時間一樣
就是營收創歷史新高
那今天來講
股價有出現比較明顯的壓回
趨勢還是不變
所以近期反而壓回
就因為AI放慢的言論
或者是這個禮拜
有可能因為
這FOMC升息的一個情況下
如果壓回
我覺得這裡都還是
可以做承接的動作
好 如果營收很好
而股價大幅回檔
你是最喜歡的啦
是 沒錯
但是現階段
台股的基本面已經好成這樣
所以很難看到那種劇烈的回檔
因此只要他在這邊盤整
而營收持續保持良好的
你都覺得是一個首選
是
好 這邊非常謝謝明漢
謝謝
好 明漢幫我們一項一項講對不對降規降速禁止發展停止發展暫停發展以前就有过啦但是现在不可能AI大厂的头都洗下去了所以川普才会打了这通电话
给华人勋
所以这件事情
短线上应该就可以解决了
大家还是在军备竞赛
至于升息
都已经几率快九成了
所以呢
这也不太容易成为市场上的变数
除非叫做暴力式的升息
好 这些因素拿开之后
就知道大家现在虽然是观望
可是台股有那么强劲的基本面
就等一个点火
后面我们的军火库是满满的
所以今天帮大家筛出来
8月营收创历史新高
但现在股价比较受压抑的公司
提供给您做选股的参考
那广告回来小明同学要上场了
怎么又是建策
建策上一次两片变一片
股价就腰窄
现在三片变两片要打七折吗
好 散热其实需求很大
等一下小明同学跟您说
以及封测股资本支出到手了
第四季會有明顯的成長喔
好 最近盤面上
不只是總經環境的問題
在產業面上面
也经不起一点点的风吹草动
但是我们之前的经验也是这样啊
后面事情过了
股价涨回原点甚至还创高
所以是不是该把握机会呢
这边来请教小明同学了
今天一开始看到建策跌停板
就想又怎么了
就市场上就说了
三片要降归
降归成几片我是不清楚
等一下你会帮我们讲
但今天建策是没有所住的
可见同样的事情再来一次
大家不会那么样的惊慌了
但散热今天有点被影响
另外台積電的擴產也在持續啊
風測其實8月的時候已經很好了
現在看起來第四季會更好
因為我們盤中啊
我說真的台股真的不缺利空
我覺得莫名其妙
我們在行情開始震盪的時候
那種利空的鬼故事就會跑出來
當然我個人還是會特別去關注一下
籌碼的變化
以目前來講啦
外資的這個空單幾萬口
我覺得明天要結算
明天要結算
那大家其實說真的也不太在意
因為大家也都知道
外資現在這裡有很多的
都是那種避險性的空單
所以你不太能夠期待說
外資的空單全部回補
然後甚至變成再做多
那反而是在散戶的微台
這個才是讓我最擔心的
原本我們在上禮拜 上上禮拜的時候
一度看到圍台翻空
哇 太好了
那也確實啦
後面這邊伴隨著是股價呢
一度要去挑戰歷史高
可是在現階段
圍台包含在今天喔
跌了三四百點
但是呢
現在三大法人賣了將近800億
結果圍台散戶在這邊還加
這邊多單 加了4000多口
這個是讓我有點擔心啦
所以我們對於明天的結算
我個人是認為
它不要大跌應該就好了
那一方面也是因為現在沒有量能
再加上FOMZ利率決策會議在即
市場的氛圍會比較偏向觀望
搭配到現在目前的籌碼
其實我們就算好啦
它不會有什麼太大的波動
我們也不能期待說它會大漲
至少籌碼現在的這個狀況
老實講比較偏空一點
可是也不需要擔心
原因是因為既然我們在結算前
成交量能就先萎縮
而且市場的情緒觀望
代表我們這兩天
正在逐步的消化利空
那你消化掉的利空
後面再有什麼利空
它的衝擊就不會這麼大
那我們來聊一下關於今天盤通的鬼故事
看到的時候我是覺得想說
哈哈又來了 怎麼似曾相識
對啊 為什麼是同樣的故事
然後打到跌停板
那我先告訴大家這一次的傳言好了
第一個是關於Robin Ultra
他的HBM41從12層改成8層
這個傳聞其實是有可能的
原因是因為你記憶體
真的就是拿不到料嘛 缺貨
可是所謂的TDP也就是熱功耗
要從2.3千瓦降到1.8千瓦
這件事情第一個我沒辦法驗證
第二個我也認為不太可能
那現在重點是
Rubin Ultra會不會從原本的說到三片
改回兩片式的均熱片
這個也是有可能的
之前不是在講兩片變一片嗎
兩片變一片嗎
那等一下我來講一下這個一片兩片三片
到底是什麼東西好了
但重點就是呢
你今天改回兩片有沒有可能
有可能因為三片的良率
你還沒有這麼的高
所以你先用兩片的
你可能到了下一代的Rubin Ultra
再慢慢的導入三片也有機會
所以這個是有可能
那你要講說建設掉單
這個就完全不合理
因為不管是兩片式還是三片式
建設都是供應商
都是他拿
上一次的故事
我們有跟大家分享
都還沒發生
他現在正在出貨中
就開始股價腰斬了
所以你看當時建設股價腰斬了
股價後面又創新高
事後回頭看這些利空
都是讓我們去撿這種
好公司便宜的好時機
好 現在兩片式指的是什麼呢
這個是晶片 GPU
OK 好不好
然後你晶片
它不可能直接去跟金屬接觸
所以你中間一定要有所謂的導熱材那我們講的一片兩片三片指的是什麼你GPU晶片上面有幾個金屬件這個就是我們的定義所以你會看到這裡第一個散熱蓋是一個
水冷板是第二個
所以這叫兩片式
三片式是什麼呢
我中間有一個加強的結構件
還有一個關鍵三件式
就是多了這個可拆上蓋
這是第二個金屬件
第三個是什麼水冷板
所以這叫做三件式
OK 所以這個大家搞清楚了
好那現在三件式厲害的地方在哪裡呢
我們剛才講了重點在可拆上蓋
這個東西是什麼呢
我在封裝之前 出廠之前
我有這個機構鍵 我把它按在晶片上
因為晶片很脆弱
你如果不小心封裝去碰到
那片晶片就壞掉
所以如果你有一個東西可以去做保護
那這樣子很好
可是因為你任何的散熱
中間的東西越多 散熱的效率越差
所以它厲害的地方在哪
我今天封裝完
我上到這個所謂的機櫃裡面以後
我這一塊可以把它拆掉
我這一塊一拆掉以後呢
我的晶片基本上除了中間的導熱材
我直接跟水冷板貼在一起
散熱效率就很好
可是就是因為你要做這個
它的量率沒有這麼的高
因此我們看到的三片市跟兩片市
我們等於是順便幫大家介紹
那你說不管是兩片市還是三片市
說真的 現側都是供應商
所以我認為這個利空鬼故事
盤中一度殺到跌停
後面很多出來辟謠
說是假消息或怎麼樣的
所以跌停板有打開
代表市場是可以接受
這個其實並不是真的大利空
好 而且有很多的股價
因為創歷史新高了
難免它有長了很多的預期
一旦這個預期有點變化的可能性
它就下來了
其實現在市場
投資市場就是很容易這樣子
我們對啊 股價在高檔
那個眼裡是容不下一力殺的
那我們以股價型態
這根長黑黑
從技術面來講很醜
非常的醜
因為它跌破了所有短中長期的均線
可是我們回到過去
我們有一台持光機
從這邊下來的
對 一度下來
從5000多塊下來的
下到這邊2800嘛
那當時也是利空故事嘛
你說這邊叫打對折
因為兩片變一片
這裡來打7折嗎
如果真的打7折
你真的要站滿方
我覺得不會啦
6 7 42
不太容易 不太容易
這邊的話我們已經驗證過了
當你建設這邊的底部成型
他呢照理來講
不應該要跌回這邊
跌回這邊反而真的不能賣
所以我會認為今天呢
一旦跌破了月線
他都是抄跌啦
都是抄跌
所以這邊的投信的籌碼還在
外資雖然小占賣方
可是我們相信的是公司的基本面
以及我們能夠知道的是
建設他不會掉單
因此這邊的股價跌得越多
反而都是減便宜的好機會好 不過曉明這一波投信厲害了他其實這邊布最多就是底部起漲區有沒有可能遇到投信的調節的話展望朋友們要稍微留意一下這倒是有可能
因為我們相好時間來到了9月
左右中旬過後
那會有所謂的投信的季底作帳
如果我們看到投信在這邊
開始有連續性的賣單
我是覺得可以先閃一下
等到季底作帳結束以後
我再把它買回來
也是一種策略
那當然啦 我們既然講到了散熱
這個散熱在接下來到年底之前
應該營收還是會越越高
在目前來講第一個
我們也看到了這個所謂的冷能專區
什麼是冷能
這個大家其實生活都會遇到
有沒有煮過那個小火鍋 瓦斯罐
你煮一煮那個瓦斯罐會變冰喔
這它是會變冰的
誰會去在煮火鍋的時候摸那個瓦斯罐啊
因為我是負責換瓦斯的那個人
所以大家會知道
當今天液態的天然氣
它要氣化
它就要吸周圍的熱
所以它會有很多的冷能
像冷氣一樣
這個時候中油有很多的液態天然氣
如果我把資料中心蓋在旁邊
我是不是就可以把這個冷能呢
直接拿來降溫
所以這是冷能專區
也就代表散熱重要
因為美國銀行就預測了
你在接下來
有將近七成的資料中心
全部都會用到液冷散熱的技術
因此我們台廠的相關概念股
這個訂單長線來看一定是沒有問題
我們今天幫大家挑了
8月營收年增超過20%
以及今年前8個月累計營收
超過25%的相關的概念股
那我們今天在這邊去做挑選的話
一樣整理了鎖定率
就是我們主力券商
買超的集中度
目前來看高率其實還是蠻高的
那其他來講的話
雙紅也是高
其他像是這種大型的龍頭股
我們有講過
他的這個鎖定率通常不會太高
可是我們就可以去參考
然後另外還整理了
預估的本益比給大家參考
所以第一間我們來跟大家介紹
3324的雙紅
前面是真的達人秀很開心
因為我們常常覺得雙紅太委屈
現隆也常常講
但後來漲了
那現在回檔到月線
是不是第二次的機會
絕佳機會
因為今天的最低點
你幹嘛那麼開心
我很喜歡股價跌啊
應該是跌了我們才有機會減便宜
今天低點1240
可是你看到月線是1236
所以代表月線這個位置是有支撐
再加上大戶的籌碼
不離不棄
變那麼多
而且這一波你看外資買上來
其實這一波修正下來
並不是外資殺的
也就代表外資的成本
還是在相對比較高檔的位置
因此股價回到月線
對我來講
我們都知道營收在下半年來講的話
不會是太大的問題
所以這種股價
既然來到了關鍵的均線支撐
那對我來講
後面只要有任何一根長紅K或許就是進場的機會再來第二間公司我們看2308的台達店長得跟別人不一樣今天逆勢對啊 送暖送暖以目前來講這個地方的形態還是空頭
這個我們也必須要這樣講
外資投信實在對他滿狠的
這邊的包含他
投信他完全沒有要回頭買
那甚至外資在這邊
也都還是賣大於買
因此籌碼的角度來講的話
他依然不是一個
你可以放到口袋名單
可是我們講了龍頭的全持股的大公司
你一定就是要趁著他股價大幅度修正
你才可以買的安心
你不能等他股價後面又漲上去
就像大力光像聯發科
一定是低檔買
你才會買的比較放心
買的比較舒服
所以台達電在這邊
預計要整理多久
我可以告訴大家
因為季線正在下彎
什麼時候會上彎
因為現在的季線的扣底值在這邊
我們可以看到以季線的扣底值
如果在這裡的話呢
他應該在後面還要整理將近一個月
他才會開始往上走
可是說真的
這種在低位階的股票
我們就是用時間來去換取空間
所以台達電的目前的本益比來講
對我 我會認為其實算是合理
因此如果後面這裡
不要去破這個1425的話
在這個位置上面
你買起來放 買起來蹲
應該到年底之前
都會有不錯的報酬空間可以期待
以今年來說
可能本益比還沒有到很低
可是如果對於明年的成長性的話
明年本益比現在的股價是低的
對 現在的股價就是低的
20幾倍
所以我會覺得是可以關注啦
那再來第二個部分
就是我們關於先進製程
先進封裝的部分
大家一直覺得說
為什麼封測股要動不動的
可是我給大家一個觀念
你隨著台積電
不管是在2奈米的製程
3奈米的製程
甚至下一代1.4奈米的製程
他們的投片量越來越多
你的封測的需求
一定也會跟著上升
特別是在COLS先進封裝
今年年底13萬片
這個已經是連續兩年
幾乎是翻倍成長
你到了2028年底以後
這個數字還要再翻倍到26萬片
也就代表的是
我們台灣相關的封測供應鏈
未來至少兩三年的訂單
你絕對就是你有產能
他都會把它拿走
所以我會認為封測族群
近期的股價雖然沒有什麼表現
但那只是因為資金現在在觀望
從基本面來講的話
他們都是非常強勁的
其實8月營收
他們已經開始陸陸續續有展現成長性了
因為說實話上半年封測成長性還好而已
是不是因為現在產能
還要等待擴出來之後
才有辦法進一步的跳增
沒錯 因為現在他們的營收數字公布出來
這個數字不是他的天花板
是台積電COWAS產能的天花板
所以我們知道COWAS的產能
在今年第四季
大量的設備跟機台交進
會瞬間拉高
大家要期待這件事
所以我對於第四季
這一些相關的封測的營收數字
是非常有期待的
同樣的我們一樣去從這一些
去做營收年增去做篩選
而且以預估本益比
我們也幫大家算好了
這邊看起來估值
都其實都算蠻合理的
第一間我們就來看3711的日月光
這個日月光高檔震盪
這個很折磨人
我挺擔心他過了一個月
還是長這樣
我們就講了一整個月他這樣
但獲利他的營收就是跳起來的
年增有到四五十%了
它的營收數字就是不會讓大家失望的
那我會認為在均線附近這邊整理
你這邊整理夠久以後
他就是讓一些沒有耐心的籌碼被消化掉
而且你看這邊的外資
其實是一直站在買方的
所以既然他在這邊蹲
他就有點類似在吸籌碼
那我們講了
如果指數在這邊是要往上去創高的話
不就代表龍頭股
應該在後面也要跟著帶頭
在封測裡面
日月光既然能夠拿到台積電後段
這一個所謂COWAS的後面的WAS的部分
還有前段他在扣的部分
也要拿到外衣的訂單
因此我會認為以日月光投控
目前的本益比真的是有一點委屈
這個股價創高的話
只要後面台股我說了
我們往5萬點或4萬8千點去做挑戰
日月光在這裡整理完以後
只要一根長紅K
那個就是一根穿雲件
千軍萬馬來相見
大家要把握
要把它放到口袋名單
觀察什麼時候去做突破表態
好
第二間公司我們來講
6223的旺系
以整個探偵測試來講的話
今天第一個工上賞的
也是雍智科技
雖然後面漲停有打開
可是我可以告訴大家
以探針測試這個基座
不管你做後面的FT Final Time的測試
或者是你在探針卡的消耗上
數量今年一定會大幅度的增加
所以目前旺系來講在探針卡族群
我認為在龍頭
我們這個族群裡面
他一定是龍頭
那我現在觀察的
就是投信近期開始重新站回買方
外資這邊的動向還沒有那麼明確
可是投信一樣的
他願意在這個位置上面去做佈局
股價距離前低
說真的其實沒有很遠
所以法說會過後的股價修正
我們現在又回到了
法說會修正下來的那個相對低點
而我會認為在探偵族群裡面
我喜歡龍頭的公司
因此在今年第二季
他就單季繳出了
EPS 15.55的數字
8月的營收年幀率也將近七成
這種股價只要有修正到這邊
相對比較低位階的話
如果後面這幾天又有震盪
盤中又跌到了平盤下
對我來講
他就是在聯準會利率決策會議前
最好卡位的時機點好 等於現在是一個找寶物的時間對不對噴出再買的話風險比較高不妨現在來找一下沒有錯喔這邊非常謝謝小明同學
謝謝兆花
好 小明同學要說
散熱絕對是在AI發展中
各個機櫃
不管層數越用越多
耗能越用越高
一定要用的標配啦
所以像現在建策又講到
不管是兩片變一片
三片變兩片
這樣的利空消息
對於未來
它股價能不能再回到新高
其實我們還是充滿了信心
不妨看一下
因为32族群前阵涨得比较多
趁着压回
大家才有再次布局的机会
而台达电搞不好
就是已经跌够了的代表
也值得您关注
那另外封测
我们讲了好几次
CORS不是一定要
一定要用产能爆满吗
就是因为爆满了
所以上半年
可能营收成长性还好
但第四季产能开出来
就要迎接封测股的
营收爆发季
好 广告回来
现龙要上场了
现龙要帮我们找大户在哪里
这几天资安股很热
但不是一两日的行情
因为大户是真的在布局
以及有一些错沙谷
回档了10起20%
又搭拉大地光等等的
能不能重新上车
等一下现龙帮您做解释了
现龙不但要帮我们看大户在哪里
还有一件事情很重要
现在已经9月中了
也等于是第三季的成绩
很多公司自己内部已经知道了
那还有谁知道
县隆也要提早帮我们找
因为投信现在要卡位
第三季季报会厉害的公司
半年报台结出来没多久
我们已经要找第三季会创高的黑马了
这就是你的任务了
再来是大户
因为资安股我们知道
其实都蛮物美价廉的
可是成交量小
那大户会这次卡位吗
之前也飙过一大段
好的 那第一个
我们还是先来谈一下
大盘指数的部分好了
因为最近中秋节快到了
到底会不会变盘
很多人都在这边
下个礼拜才中秋节
那更多人在看到形态都觉得说
大盘上次涨到48 218
这次涨到47 578
好像这地方过不去前波高点
会不会变成一个M头
不要乱化
所以这个部分
第一个我们先看融资余额的部分
你有没有发现到
如果说大盘现在是
融资余额已经不断的在创新
可是指數過不了前高
那就要小心
那就可能這是地方代表說敞戶一直在買指數上不去大戶在調節這樣的狀況這个大盘形成M头的几率就很大可是目前呢你会发现融资余额
到昨天为止5838亿
距离之前的高峰
6333亿
大概少了将近500亿
那500亿将近有1000亿的股票
你说跑到哪里去
股票不会变少啊
那就代表说
融资之前砍掉的股票
现在都还在大户手中
所以既然筹码面
在大户手中
融资予而比高峰
减少来500亿的情况之下
这个行情就不容易形成
所谓的M头
那第二个
还有一个更重要的关键
在成交量
现在量缩到只有这个
6000亿上下而已
那当然主要原因因
焊测筹签
冻结了将近9000亿的
9000亿
本来说5、6000就很多
还9000亿啊
对啊
但是做股票高手
都会是等到这种
窒息量出现的时候
记得一个原则
量缩
那叫做股底
微股
量大反而会成风
三月底的时候
那时候很多人也是在这里
也有画了一个M头出来
这边也画过是不是
对啊 量也是说到这地方
五六千亿
大家觉得这个地方是不是行情
岌岌可危啊
那时候我们对他讲
这个拉回来反而常多格局不变
回到基前
你看到真的就是一个好买点
量说你去放空
就空一横
等到量大
1.8兆的量出来
47,000 48,000的时候
五六月一堆人强劲
那个反而后面都套牢在一堆被动元件身上
所以我们才会说量小做空会空遗恨
量大做多反而多套牢
那这样改变这种
你就要懂得真正高手会去量小的时候
进场就先买好股票
等到量大的时候
你就等着快乐数钞票就好
对应今天的志习让大家应该觉得希望来了吧
那当然这个部分我们接下来寻找说
有哪些股票大户在连买
或是投信已经有在卡位了
例如第三报的一个财报行情
那不过最近有些股票
是在地方股价跌下来了
很多人也都在问
这个跌下来可不可以接啊
大力光昨天我们还在救他
今天只跌了玉京光也是
还有精彩的很多
散物朋友也在关心的
最近几天就跌了快两成
有达加登
那这个部分来看的话
当然第一个大力光的股价
7995的高点
大概就出现在8月底9月初
那时候是细光子论坛登场
后来股价就跌跌跌
跌到这两天最低
5995跌了2000塊不見了
不過就結構上來看
第一個它還是算是一個多頭的結構高有過高拉回目前回測月線但月線還是上揚而且大戶的部分至少到上個禮拜為止還是有持續在增持
零三週做加碼的動作
那包括外資的部分
外資是這地方
先前說調降平等很賣出
目標談到剩下5000塊的價位
認為說股價真的過高了
可是發現到從5月8號
從這個地方
最近5個交易地
就9月8號以來
外資是9月7號出的報告
結果這5天外資沒有賣
反而還買了209張
所以籌碼面來看
雖然外資在還賣
但是實際上有偷偷在買的動作
我覺得倒是可以觀察一下
那怎麼去做進場呢
通常這種個股
股價漲多拉回要做進場
第一個我們要先尋找
支撐有沒有能夠去確認守得住
那刀子還在往下掉的時候
我們也常講不用急著去接
但是如果有轉強訊號出現
我們就可以來做進場
那通常轉強訊號
我們會等說第一根紅棒去突破
前一天黑K的一個高點
那舉個例子就像大力光
這一波從7995跌到
這個禮拜一的時候
還殺到5995
一根黑K下去
那今天稍微個反彈
但是還沒有過昨天的高點
所以這個部分我們還會先觀察
那昨天的高點大概在6400左右
如果能夠順利的讓它突破過去
拉回來當然不要去破這個
8月25號起漲長紅5295的低點
这个时候就有正式的转强
到时候这个地方
我觉得大力光机会
这个机会就会
让投资可以把握一下了
那还有一档精彩的部分
台积电子公司前阵子好夯
以创历史新高
忽然就连三黑
那通常这种股票
我们就会去观察
第一个多头结构我讲过
还是没有改变
高有过高
拉回回测月线而已
那但是呢
这地方我们就先找它的支撑点
支撑就可以观察
这里投信8月28号开始
连续三天买超
所以這個地方代表投薪的成本
最低大概在350的位置
不能夠去跌破
那不要去跌破
通常拉回來大概接近他的一成左右
350大概一成大概385左右
會是一個比較好的介入點
當然如果說不想要再接刀子的
也可以去觀察一下
拉回來如果說
比如說今天還是一根長黑
還不用急著接
如果明天或是接下來
能天能夠突破前面黑K棒的高點
比如說430的價位
明天就給它降回去
那他就有洗盤完成
準備再展公式的機會
也是可以來做觀察
來做留意的
那最後還有一個半導體設備加燈
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕